guess what the minimalists are going on
tour with a live version of the
minimalists podcast
and i want to invite you to join us for
a night of less find your nearest city
at the minimalists comm slash tour we'll
see you there
how old were you when when the
disordered eating started was 11 my my
mom actually had a history with eating
disorders she had been hospitalized for
anorexia a few times and she had
introduced me to anorexia and because
she thought it would help me play
younger roles for acting all right I
thought if I stayed smaller it would be
effective Wow and so it was right which
is like that's the other the other the
other mess the part about is you
actually get some sort of rewards from
the universe because of the disordered
living and the same is true in other
areas of disordered living if we are
constantly lying to inflate ourselves it
can help us out in the short term as
well but it sort of kills us literally
figuratively metaphysically in a way
that is harder to quantify because and
with with the anorexia and then
eventually eventually how were you when
the the bulimia started I was 21 Wow
yeah and and but you this was also
modeled for you by your mom the anorexia
part yet you talked about how basically
for dinner all you ever saw her was
broccoli and and cauliflower with a
little bit of like garlic salt on it
yeah it was just vegetables she wouldn't
eat anything else for dinner so yeah I
learned that's that's normal that's what
I saw as normal yeah and so eventually
manifested into bulimia but then that
that morphed into feeling like you were
you weren't you weren't a good enough
bulimic yeah well because in in like
eating disorder land you're never you're
never a mning for bulimia like the ideal
there's definitely a hierarchy to eating
disorders and you're like you want to
have anorexia if you have any dessert if
you have a bulimia you basic if you have
bulimia you basically failed at nrx
like that's that's just what you know
you tried to eat amateur in a row yes
yes you tried to not eat you couldn't
not eat so then you ate and then you
throw up what you ate you feel the hyrax
yeah you landed a bulimia is kind of how
it goes yeah and so in dealing with that
you also then had not just having the
sort of unjustified body images but
about body image issues but but then you
had this can it's the opposite of
competitive eating its competitive not
eating in a way where where you had
other people who were in your age range
where you'd show up at events and red
carpets and other things and there was
sort of a hierarchy in a way right yeah
well it's this very kind of unspoken
rule I feel like in young Hollywood of
you know if you're at a Teen Vogue party
and they're passing around hors
d'oeuvres and you you're in the middle
of a conversation and you go to grab an
hors d'oeuvre it's like you'll get the
side-eye from another person like oh my
you're taking a crostini like this is
insane that down like it's just this
very you can just feel the pressure of
it you can feel everybody kind of body
monitoring food monitoring everybody
else in their room it's just it's just
such a part of the business
I think let's talk about the the
recovery process because it was not an
overnight recovery no I thought it was I
was like once I made the decision to
recover like this is gonna be great I'm
just gonna like what what I realized
during recovery was that my eating
disorder and my addiction to it had
really been covering up all of the
uncomfortable feelings underneath it so
then once I was pushing for recovery
I was just confronted with all those
feelings that I've been bottling I've
been suppressing and shoving down for so
long and that was so difficult you know
I'd been burying them for 13 years and I
never imagined that not throwing up
not that what how it relieved my anxiety
so much that not throwing up would leave
me in a fetal position on the floor
sobbing like it was that emotional to me
where it was like oh this was just
covering up Oh
this and yeah it was difficult it was it
was it was that that level of emotional
intensity you know the the fetal
position sobbing for at least a year
yeah you I saw on Twitter you were
starting a eating disorder podcast if
you have you started doing that yeah
I've started I'm in like the
experimental phase I've done six
episodes but I don't think it's good
enough yet so I'm gonna do a bunch more
before putting it up okay when it comes
out we'll make sure we we get it out
there in the world well thank you well
tell all the folks about it I would
really encourage you to read this
article we can't do it justice in the
short time we have here but I did find
it to be really powerful the it's
amazing what doors our parents and
advertently open up for us and in your
mom's case it was probably out of sense
of love and caring in some warped way
where she felt like this was the best
thing to do and so at least in her own
thinking I'm assuming right yeah I have
I had such a I have such a complex
relationship with her mom I think all of
us do it's just what it is but I know
the way when I sympathize with her most
it's when I realized that she was just
desperate for me to have a better life
than she had it's really the bottom line
she wanted me to be successful and
well-liked and what have you her means
of doing that was were you know
desperate and detrimental to her
parenting and my well-being but but on
some level I know that it's just because
she wanted me to do well
you